foreign
to make a car you need some seriously
heavy metal
take iridium a super tough atom with 77
protons that's used to coat the tips
spark plugs
next on the heavyweight lineup comes
gold with 79 protons
this shiny conductor resists corrosion
making it ideal for exposed electrical
connections
these connectors here for this airbag
assembly are gold and so this thing can
react really quickly if there's an
accident and save your life
the biggest atom in the car is lead with
82 protons
only lead has the durability to deliver
the short burst of high power needed to
start an engine over and over again
foreign but until very recently how the
universe made these oversized atoms was
a complete mystery the you can't make
gold items in a normal star
you can't make gold atoms in a massive
star that's dying
in order to make atoms this big with
this many neutrons you need a truly
cataclysmic event
just a few years ago most scientists
believe that supernovas were cataclysmic
enough to do the job
but astronomer Edo Burger was not so
sure
if you open any one of these books and
flip to the page that tells you where
gold came from it will tell you that
gold came from Supernova explosions
but nobody had directly observed
supernovas producing elements like gold
and inside computer simulations virtual
supernovas lack the energy to forge
these oversized atoms
clearly something was wrong but if
supernovas weren't powerful enough what
in the universe was
Forum heavy elements requires a lot of
neutrons and so another possible theory
was that the heaviest elements were
produced in the mergers of two neutron
stars in a binary system
neutron stars are some of the weirdest
objects in the universe
they're formed from the collapsed cores
of big stars when they die you're taking
a couple of times the mass of the Sun
and squeezing it down into a ball that's
only a few miles across the electrons
and the protons that are flitting around
inside of that combine to form neutrons
and what you're left with is an
extremely dense ball of neutrons about
the size of a city
neutron stars are extremely dense if you
take just a teaspoon of the neutron star
material it's actually a billion tons
if neighboring Stars die together it's
possible for the two neutron stars they
leave behind to form a spinning binary
pair but the partnership is doomed
what you're left over with is two
incredibly compact dramatic objects
spiraling around each other
[Music]
over time they move in together until
finally they can coalesce in the most
violent explosion since the Big Bang
the explosion is called a neutron star
merger
the amount of energy
in this explosion is crushing there's
almost no way to describe it it's like
taking all of the sun's energy that it
will ever emit over its entire lifetime
and releasing it in a single second
Burger suspects this colossal explosion
forges iridium gold and Lead but to
rewrite the textbooks he needs hard
evidence
it was difficult to convince the
community that this was a potential
channel for the production of heavy
elements
the proof is to actually see this
process happening in the universe
[Applause]
June 2013 NASA's Swift satellite spots a
short burst of gamma rays from a nearby
Galaxy
sure sign that a neutron star merger has
just taken place
[Applause]
Burger it's the lucky break he's been
waiting for
as soon as we knew that there was a
gamma-ray burst nearby we knew that this
was our one chance for perhaps several
years to obtain the right kind of
measurements to test the formation of
heavy elements
one swift that identified the burst the
Hubble Space Telescope swung into action
to capture images
we grabbed them right away and we just
looked we knew exactly where to look at
the center of this red circle and what
we saw was this Source right there in
the middle that is the direct signature
of the production of very heavy elements
including gold
Burger's theory was right but the rate
of production was way higher than he'd
expected well in that one event the
amount of gold that was produced was
more than the mass of the Earth
if we can bring it all here it would be
worth quadrillions and quadrillions of
dollars
[Applause]
the theory is still very new but it's
possible that ancient neutron star
mergers made all the heavy metals we see
in the world today including the last
remaining ingredients for our car
[Music]
but all these elements are still
floating free in space
[Music]
what's needed now is to pull them all
together into one giant fabrication
plant
this is what your car looked like before
the Earth was born just a vast swirling
cloud of gas and Stardust the exploded
remains ancient Stars
the clouds between the stars of the
Galaxy are made of everything that the
Earth your body and your car is made of
there's everything that you need
floating in gaseous form between the
Stars
four and a half billion years ago the
gas and dust collapse once more
explosively to create a new star our sun
close to the young Sun all of the
lighter stuff got blown away what was
left behind was the heavier denser stuff
[Music]
there was carbon there was iron there
was gold everything in between
[Music]
over time these free floating elements
begin to coalesce dust becomes Rock
s join to form larger objects called
planetesimals
finally planetesimals join to form the
Earth
[Music]
our planet is born with all the
ingredients to build a car
those ingredients are about to go their
separate ways
the Earth is a big planet and it's done
something that not all planets do it's
differentiated it's melted
copper and Lead dissolve and sulfur and
Float to the top of the molten Earth
making these Metals easy to mine today
but precious metals like iridium and
gold sink to the core of the earth and
most of the iron sinks with it
kind of a pain actually all the heavy
elements that are super useful like iron
they've sunk to the middle of the Earth
where we can't reach them and there's
not a whole lot of it in the crust
[Music]